[Música]
en primera plana
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio france internacional y de
france 24 esta semana ponemos los focos
en la segunda ola de comida aquí en
europa por fin con algunas noticias
esperanzadoras hoy nos acompañan en este
estudio beatriz juez corresponsal del
diario 'el correo' aquí en francia
bienvenida a beatriz vélez arrunátegui
periodista independiente especializada
en temas económicos bienvenida del ya
sacarla y en dúplex desde bruselas la
corresponsal de ref y esther herrera
buenos dias stern
hola buenos días la segunda ola de la
pandemia aquí en europa hoy en primera
plana
bueno pues buena parte de europa está
confinada tras una segunda ola de la
pandemia mucho más virulenta de lo que
casi todos pudimos imaginar y por fin
estos días primeros datos para la
esperanza en cuanto por ejemplo la
ralentización de contagios en algunos
países como por ejemplo a francia
mientras las noticias de las
farmacéuticas sobre las vacunas también
han ayudado en los últimos días a crear
un clima moderadamente más optimista hoy
hacemos balance de esta segunda ola
preguntándonos además si la unión
europea puede salir más fortalecida de
esta pandemia y con muchos piensan que
se cumpla aquello de que detrás de una
crisis hay una oportunidad repasemos
antes algunas portadas de la prensa
diario le parisien el confinamiento va a
prolongarse la pregunta es cómo salvar
la navidad la vanguardia en españa el
gobierno catalán prevé una navidad con
toques de queda y poca movilidad en
bélgica le soir la vacuna será gratuita
y no obligatoria objetivo llegará al 70%
de la población
bueno muchos gobiernos europeos
pretenden salvar las navidades como
decían las portadas es decir que en
estas fechas podamos reunirnos y también
poder consumir no se vea ser esto
posible bueno habrá que ver como imagino
que cada país será diferente aquí el
gobierno hace unos días dijo que las
reuniones de familia iban a tener que
ser pequeñas que no iban a poder haber
no sé 20 personas cenando juntas y que
había que olvidarse un poco de fin de
año fiestas de fin de año porque aparte
no va a haber locales donde reunirse
pero bueno veremos finalmente qué es lo
que pasa y una pequeña esperanza quizá
lo que lo que parece claro de él ya es
que nadie ni nadie pensamos que esta
segunda ola fuera a ser tan virulenta
como en rey de así que lo está haciendo
está siendo virulenta pero por suerte se
está llegando a controlar más rápido de
lo esperado eso también da un poco de
aire de esperanza y que espera que
tenemos instrumentos que no tenemos en
la primera los test y conocimiento de
cómo funciona más o menos el virus y
cómo poder
a la circulación tan grande para lo de
las fiestas de navidades yo creo que
antes que nada el gobierno el gobierno
tendría que flexibilizar el
confinamiento para permitir que la gente
pueda circular un poco más libre en todo
en todo caso estamos hablando en este
caso de francia esther herrera
corresponsal de recién bruselas esta
semana hablando de europa conocíamos que
polonia y hungría han bloqueado los
fondos de recuperación europeos que es
la clave porque no aceptan que se
condicione el acceso de los fondos al
respeto estricto del estado de derecho
en los países miembros algo que por otra
parte parece un poco sorprendente que lo
hagan países europeos que supone en
cuanto a tiempos o a retrasos estos
vetos y cómo pretende salir la unión
europea de este bloqueo externo
bueno pues eso es una buena pregunta
porque las capitales europeas y también
desde bruselas están un poco hartos de
esta situación porque todo ha sido como
una carrera de obstáculos en que cuando
creen que se ha llegado al final de
repente te sale un obstáculo más ahora
mismo la situación está encallada en una
videoconferencia el pasado jueves los
líderes europeos prometieron seguir
negociando para convencer de alguna
forma a polonia y hungría como pues
posiblemente con algún tipo de recurso
legal que les garantice que no habrá
ninguna persecución ideológica porque
estos países es lo que están asegurando
pero no se puede retrasar todo mucho
porque el 1 de enero de 2021 debería
estar ya todo listo qué pasaría si esto
no pasa pues que no tenemos presupuesto
y apenas había dinero solo para
cuestiones de emergencia como por
ejemplo la ayuda humanitaria también
para pagar a los funcionarios o la ayuda
a agricultores pero se paralizarían
muchas otras cosas y luego está el plan
de recuperación de 750.000 millones de
euros que ayudaría a los países a salir
mejor de la crisis económica derivada
del
así que desde bruselas nadie esconde que
la situación realmente es muy crítica
del plan europea el plan este plan
europeo tiene suficientes garantías como
para salir de la crisis mejor al menos
que el de 2008 yo creo que es bueno
también tener en cuenta que cada crisis
la de 2008 y estas son diferentes la del
2008 era una crisis netamente financiera
y el plan estaba adaptado a corto plazo
para inyectar capitales para para ayudar
a salir de esta crisis este plan es
diferente y es más a mediano o largo
plazo lo que también genera un poco más
de confianza porque es este está pensado
para que funcione con mecanismos no
solamente pensados directamente para
salir de coronavirus de la crisis de
coronavirus sino también apoyar el
desarrollo de tecnologías este
ecológicas amigables con el medio
ambiente yo creo que sí es un poco más
estructurado
y es un poco más si tiene más garantías
y sorprende el veto de países como
polonia y hungría que que hagan veto al
plan simplemente porque se condicione
algo que en europa debe estar tan
solventado y tan como que se respeten
los derechos más elementales no sí es
sorprendente pero pregona una parte
parece más un pulso y una jugada de
póquer más que porque tampoco van a
quedarnos como los parias no polonia y
hungría que al final ellos también son
los que se van a beneficiar también de
las ayudas entonces imagen en estos
momentos cualquier dinero que venga de
donde venga es bienvenido porque no los
gobiernos están gastando mucho y no
tienen dinero así que imagino que al
final al final como esto es una jugada
de póquer y al final acabarán cediendo
bueno pues son dos son de los 27 pero
bueno problema de la unión europea es
ese siempre que tienen que tomar
decisiones por unanimidad y con 27 es
muy difícil antes con mejor con 15 era
más fácil pero ahora con 27 es bastante
difícil pero hablemos de las vacunas y
de la estrategia de la unión europea
actualmente la umh europea tiene
contratos con 5
compañías farmacéuticas y se asegura
1200 millones de dosis
esther como es la estrategia de la umh
europea para la disposición de las
vacunas europa pretende con esta
estrategia que no se reproduzca digamos
los episodios del sálvese quien pueda de
las mascarillas
pues durante los primeros meses de la
pandemia la comisión europea propuso
centralizar la compra de vacunas
teniendo primero contactos con las
grandes farmacéuticas que ya habían
empezado a investigar los países
europeos accedieron a que bruselas
encargada y así es sería muchísimo más
fácil la adquisición de estas vacunas la
estrategia europea ha sido bastante
inteligente porque se ha basado en tener
primero unos pre contratos con varias
farmacéuticas y así asegurarse que la
salga primero que esté autorizada y se
considere segura según la agencia
europea del medicamento entonces puede
acceder rápidamente al mercado europeo y
luego hay ahí varias fases en que se
negocia siempre a prueba y finalmente se
firma esta adquisición pero como dices
justamente para evitar este episodio del
sálvese quien pueda
bruselas ha actuado con muchísima
discreción incluso con turismo de hecho
la comisión europea aseguró en junio que
tenía presupuestados 2.400 billones de
euros para vacunas pero nadie sabe
cuánto pagó el contrato bony hernández
tampoco kaiser además las relaciones con
formato citas en general
siempre han sido muy confidenciales
escenario con el actual en que está en
juego en las tecnologías muy punteras
también con patentes propias y que
además todo puede tener repercusiones
bursátiles pues compras secretismo se ha
llevado todo este los criterios de
distribución entre la población
bueno dependen de cada país miembro pero
lo que sí que hace bruselas son
recomendaciones
sí así es cada país podrá decidir una
vez que reciban las vacunas como
distribuirlas pero la comisión europea
ha recomendado que se dé prioridad a
trabajadores esenciales como sanitarios
o cuidadores de ancianos mayores de 60
años personas con problemas médicos que
les hagan más vulnerables y colectivos
desfavorecidos básicamente se trata de
personas que pueden tener más contacto
con el cob y 19 hombre razonable que
esos criterios nos enteremos de ellos
pues pues ahora no deberíamos ir
conociéndolos antes de que arranque el
2021 y que comencemos con el tema de las
vacunas
imagino que irán dando las noticias poco
poco a poco no porque ahora primero la
gente está concentrada en que pasará en
navidad' después de la siguiente fase
será cuando llega la vacuna el
calendario y quien va a ser a quien hay
que poner las vacunas primero no me
imagino que poco a poco lo irán diciendo
porque todavía tampoco está clara la
fecha en la que va a llegar
lo que resulta sorprendente durante
estas dos últimas semanas que hemos
tenido noticias de vacunas
la mayoría de ellas muy positivas y casi
ha sido una especie de carrera cada
noticia era mejor que la siguiente la
sensibilidad que han tenido los mercados
y las bolsas para recibir esas noticias
de forma positiva como si van disparando
las bolsas que eran una noticia que se
esperaba con mucha ansiedad y es normal
la reacción ahora vamos a ver cómo se va
generando la la estrategia de vacunación
también en tener en cuenta que las
personas estén dispuestas a vacunarse
porque es una vacuna relativamente nueva
que se está testeando en el momento
todavía no se sabe cuánto hacerlo por
cuánto tiempo va a durar la inmunidad si
son tres tres meses seis meses un año
entonces son cosas como es algo tan
nuevo
hoy hasta el momento de esperanza pero
también hay que entrar un poco en el
momento actual y dar tiempo al tiempo
respecto a esa disposición de la gente a
vacunarse en los últimos días han salido
sondeos realmente sorprendentes de la
desconfianza por ejemplo en países como
francia de gran parte de la población de
esas reticencias a la vacuna si
infraccionan una encuesta en salir hace
poco decía que sólo el 54 por ciento
piensa vacunarse
pero esto no significa que el resto sean
antivacunas dónde nos podamos esta
visión de buena vamos a esperar a ver
que se vacunen primero unos vemos si
tiene efectos secundarios y luego ya me
vacuno yo porque muchos como dice como
dice delia pues eso que no sabe muy bien
dice vamos están experimentando ahora
vamos bueno se supone que cuando se
hagan las vacunas en teoría es
totalmente segura y fiable pero hay
mucha gente que tiene miedos que es
normal también quizá esos miedos y las
desconfianzas también se han producido
por la rapidez no con la que con la que
hemos tenido que avanzar en el tema de
las vacunas exacto son vacunas que
recién están siendo testeadas con muy
buenos resultados pero no se sabe a
largo tiempo que es lo como el cuerpo
humano va reacciona entonces siempre hay
un poco de temor yo creo que en ese
momento está faltando comunicación más
comunicación sobre la vacuna en sí para
que la gente se sienta más en confianza
y con deseos de utilizar estas teorías
por ejemplo aquí en francia cuando justo
cuando la semana que ha anunciado lo de
las vacunas ha salido un documental
con un montón de teorías de complot y
conspiraciones entonces sí que ha tenido
mucho éxito las redes sociales que se
está viendo mucho entonces es eso el
miedo la esperanza del miedo hasta un
poco y la esperanza también es la
esperanza que tiene europa a salir de
toda esta crisis más fortalecida con una
especie de unión europeo de la sanidad
de ello les quiero preguntar a la vuelta
de esta paso hacemos una breve pausa y
continuamos hablando de la unión europea
y esta segunda ola de kobe aquí en
primera plana
[Música]
desde hace más de siete décadas
palestino está buscando ser un estado
reconocido pero el camino está lleno de
tropiezos israelí-palestina están
condenados a entenderse como vecinos
pero desde los 90 con la intifada todos
los acuerdos de paz han fracasado por
uno u otro motivo el último esfuerzo
viene de la mano de la administración
trump con el acuerdo del siglo favorable
a israel en sus políticas de
asentamientos pero si palestina no es un
estado no es sólo culpa de israel hay
diferencias a nivel internacional
regional y entre los propios palestinos
países como eeuu y alemania no reconocen
a palestina como estado y la liga árabe
tiene diferencias a la hora de la
cuestión palestina también los
palestinos están divididos políticamente
cisjordania pertenece al fatah y gaza al
movimiento hamás ahora además algunos
países árabes han normalizado su
relación con israel y palestina' piensa
que tendrá menos aliados en el futuro
[Música]
karabaj es una nación no reconocida
desde los años 90 ha estado a la sombra
de armenia y ahora tras una corta guerra
vuelve a las manos de azerbaiyán
hablamos de territorios acerías
controlados desde 1994 por armenia
armenia entregó ahora hace días
azerbayán 7 localidades que formaban
parte de la región de nagorno karabaj lo
hace en cumplimiento del acuerdo de alto
el fuego firmado el pasado 9 de
noviembre una paz alcanzada con la
mediación de rusia
el acuerdo establece un calendario para
la devolución a azerbaiyán de una serie
de territorios que han permanecido bajo
control armenio y también con población
armenia desde la guerra del 94 las
autoridades de nagorno karabaj han
asegurado que ya se han desplazado las
propiedades de más de 2.000 residentes
en esas siete localidades cedidas a
azerbaiyán y que los afectados van a
recibir pronto alojamiento temporal
[Música]
el sahara occidental es considerada la
última colonia de áfrica desde que
españa el antiguo poder colonial dejó el
territorio en 1975 esta región estaba en
disputa entre el reino de marruecos y el
frente polisario de liberación aunque en
este momento marruecos controla el 75
por ciento del territorio las naciones
unidas- no reconoce la soberanía de esta
región para ninguna de las dos partes
pero la unión africana sí reconoce el
derecho a la autodeterminación del
pueblo saharaui y ha permitido que sea
uno de sus estados miembros desde 1991
ha habido un cese al fuego entre
marruecos y polisario pero esto amenaza
con romperse después de que activistas
saharauis acosan a marruecos de una
operación militar el fin de semana
pasado y esto podría desencadenar en un
conflicto a gran escala después de
décadas de conflictos y de disputas
territoriales se calcula que unos
100.000 refugiados saharauis viven en
campamentos en el desierto y en
condiciones muy precarias
[Música]
siempre que hay un líder asesinado
tenemos que pensar quién se beneficia
mujeres que protagonizan la agenda
política económica social cultural del
mundo han conversado con los periodistas
de france 24 en español y no es una moda
pasajera el feminismo con la forma de
ver la realidad
seguimos aquí en primera plana hoy
analizando la segunda ola de la pandemia
en europa y los signos de esperanza que
comienzan a verse con las periodistas
beatriz juez y delia runa tegui y desde
bruselas la corresponsal de ref y esther
herrera bueno a la segunda ola está
mostrando yo creo sobre todo que nadie
puede despistarse un país que parecía
tenerla bien controlada como alemania
pues ahora tiene cifras mucho peores
italia que parecía que había entrado en
la segunda ola controlando la mucho
mejor que la primera tampoco españa que
había comenzado muy mal la segunda ola
ahora parece que los datos empiezan a
mejorar un poco es decir no tenéis la
sensación que el virus circula a veces
con criterios que por mucho que
intentemos no los llegamos a entender si
la verdad que no se entiende nada porque
en países como españa que fueron super
restrictivos al principio que el
confinamiento fue mucho más restrictivo
que aquí en francia que se pusieron
mascarillas desde el principio hubo un
montón de muertos y contagios entonces
se ha ido un poco improvisando sobre la
marcha por ejemplo aquí también al
principio decían llevar mascarilla no
sirve de nada en cambio ahora la
mascarilla fue este verano impresionante
el frasco
yo creo que ellos ni ellos mismos saben
muy bien cómo funciona el virus porque
es un virus nuevo y los científicos no
saben cómo funciona y tampoco saben muy
bien reaccionar es tampoco un poco
reaccionando sobre la marcha pero yo
creo que se está aprendiendo un poco de
los errores por ejemplo el error que
hubo de desconfiar muy rápido en
primavera ahora yo creo que el gobierno
sobre todo el francés no quiere cometer
el mismo error por eso está pensando en
en fases de desconfía miento y ya yo
creo que también el criterio de la
sociedad ha cambiado antes se pensaba un
retorno a la normalidad la normalidad
antes del cob y no ahora como que uno
entiende que no va a ser la normalidad
de antes del comicio nueva nueva
normalidad donde vamos a tener que
convivir con el virus y con ciertas
medidas para mantenerlo a un nivel
aceptable por decirlo porque el virus va
a seguir circulando la segunda ola
también ha confirmado que estrategias
como la de suecia con medidas no
restrictivas hasta ahora porque bueno a
ver qué verdad que ahora ha cambiado
suecia el resultado final ser más
mortíferas que las de otros países de su
entorno como los
escandinavo es decir esta estrategia al
final se ha demostrado que no ha
funcionado no ha funcionado es el caso
de suecia lo que ellos hicieron más que
medidas de tomar medidas de gobierno de
las ticas son recomendaciones es decir a
la gente mantenga en un metro y medio si
se sienten enfermos les recomendamos que
se queden en casa en ese momento en la
segunda ola definitivamente no ha sido
positivo ha habido un crecimiento
exponencial en los contagios el mismo
primer ministro estuvo confinado en su
casa por ser un caso contacto entonces
está bien están modificando también su
forma de combatir los contagios de una
forma más
adaptada adaptada al virus creo que
también eso se ve una evolución pero no
solamente de un país al otro sino en
general en europa ha habido una
evolución de la forma de manejar si
atendemos a los datos como decía del ya
grandes antes a partir de ahora veremos
las llamadas estrategias de desde
escalada de desconfía miento claro era
lo que menos menciona antes del ya
aprenderemos qué es la pregunta es
aprenderemos de los errores que
cometimos en el primer desconfía miento
para hacer este segundo con una
estrategia más controlada y mejor
la tercera ola yo sé porque yo creo que
también la gente si no controlar un poco
por ejemplo el del confinamiento ahora
en navidades va a pasar lo mismo que
tras confinamiento en verano que todo el
mundo va a salir se va a descontrolar
todos y como hacen por ejemplo en
cataluña que van a poner un toque de
queda no sé si sé si esa es la solución
necesaria pero creo que hay
que ir poco a poco no hay que ir pasar
como en verano que de repente pasamos
estar confinados a de repente tomando
las terrazas y en la playa hay que hacer
como poquito a poco y ver lo que lo que
pasa y si funciona no funciona confiesen
un segundo del confinamiento de forma
más pausada que en el primero quizá sí
totalmente yo creo que cuando escuchamos
a los diferentes jefes de gobierno
hablar dar mensajes se ve que ya no
existe ese optimismo que existía antes
de que bueno si vamos a retomar una vida
normal si no es mucho más medido por más
que en este momento ya comienzan a
aparecer algunas vacunas y signos de
porque ya se sabe que con el
confinamiento con los cubre fuego que
les llaman acá en francia sea se logra
parar los contagios pero igual hay un
sentido de calma de no cambiar de desde
0 a 100 que antes no existía yo creo que
si se está aprendiendo he hecho la
semana que viene creo que macrón en su
en su intervención que va a hacer para
anunciar un poco esa fase de escalada
decía la prensa que había consejeros del
que le habían recomendado no utilizar la
palabra de confinamiento
para no para no propagar esa idea a la
gente de que bueno a partir de ahora ya
ustedes pueden ayer el ministro de
sanidad estaba diciendo que no se
planteaba el des confinamiento lo dijo
claramente porque llevábamos como una
semana o dos que la prensa francesa
estaban hablando todo el rato del
confinamiento del confinamiento y vamos
a salvar las navidades y ayer empezaron
ya un poco a ponerse un poco es que los
mensajes lo que se transmite en este
tipo de fases es muy sensible verdad
porque muestra un poco el ambiente
exacto pero hay que tener en cuenta que
estas fiestas de fin de año no van a ser
como las anteriores y yo creo que la
mayoría de gente ya lo ha entendido no
van a haber fiesta grandes fiestas de
fin de año y las fiestas familiares van
a tener que ser reducidas en todo caso
si llegan a ver claro bueno el estallido
de la pandemia encontró a la unión
europea sin duda con el pie cambiado la
mayoría de los gobiernos no entendieron
la dimensión de la crisis sanitaria con
los meses se ha reaccionado y mejorando
la coordinación pero
la europea no tiene apenas competencias
en materia sanitaria que siguen siendo
verdaderamente nacionales ante este
panorama y con la idea de preparar mejor
a el bloque para las futuras pandemias
la comisión europea ha presentado sus
planes para asumir parte de esas
competencias
esther herrera bruselas por dónde van
esos planes
básicamente se trata de reforzar un poco
lo que ya tiene la unión europea por
ejemplo dotar de más poder a la agencia
europea de control y prevención de
enfermedades para que para que pueda
hacer en verdaderas recomendaciones
sanitarias los países y que éstos sigan
obsesos también la gente opera en
obtener más más para vigilar la
competencia la aportación del estado tim
y también propone la creación
experiencia que sea capaz para
emergencias además pide a los países
tenemos algún problema para escuchar a
esther son optimistas de que es respeto
que la unión europea aproveche la
circunstancia para tomar impulso
beatriz yo sí yo espero que sí porque
bueno pero que va haciendo ahora también
que haya una política europea en materia
de sanidad porque también todos los
recursos pues en vez de estar cada uno
por su parte es mejor ponernos en todos
los conocimientos con los recursos en
una juntos para poder afrontar la crisis
como están y creo que es positivo no sé
si finalmente se hará porque
europea siempre cuesta mucho sacar
cualquier decisión como hemos visto
antes con el plan de lanzamiento pero
pero bueno espero que sí espero que sea
de esta crisis por lo menos salga
salgáis pues será la crisis una
oportunidad del ya yo espero que sí creo
que sí porque se les conviene a todos
los países miembros de la unión europea
la información tiene que circular y
sobre todo información tan importante
como para salvar economías y claro la
vida de las personas y yo creo que va a
salir reforzada no sé si ya podemos
escuchar mejor a esther herrera desde
bruselas que nos estaba contando esos
planes que tiene la unión europea para
para formar una especie de unión europea
sanitaria esther cuéntanos
se trata de reforzar lo que comentábamos
que de totalmente más poder sobre todo
las agencias que ya existen por ejemplo
la agencia europea de control y
prevención de enfermedades para que
pueda hacer verdaderas recomendaciones
sanitarias en los países y que éstos
puedan seguir sus consejos también está
la agencia europea del medicamento para
tener más margen para vigilar la compra
de medicamentos o la aplicación de
ensayos médicos además se pretende crear
un lugar a hacer existe capaz de
anticiparse a futuras pandemias y pedir
a los países que sean capaces de hacer
análisis de emergencia parecido a los
test de estrés que deben pasar los
bancos para anticiparse a futuras crisis
económicas en trata de que realice esta
pandemia haga reflexionar de que aunque
nadie se imaginaba algo así es algo que
ha pasado y que puede volver a ocurrir
uno de los miedos por cierto que tenía
gracias a la unión europea es el
crecimiento de los movimientos
antivacunas hablaba antes
con ese documental de los complotistas
de los anti medios de ascó vida en
ocasiones impulsados por populismos
políticos de momento estos movimientos
ustedes lo consideran son una amenaza
real o esto sería mucho decir ahora
mismo en europa
si son una amenaza real porque yo existe
un escepticismo de la parte de la
sociedad general sobre las vacunas
nuevas que están saliendo y esto
refuerza los temores que uno ya tiene
naturales sobre algo nuevo que está
apareciendo hay que tener cuidado y la
forma de combatir estos temores es más
información más información de la parte
de las farmacéuticas y sobre todo de los
gobiernos que expliquen de qué se trata
la vacuna y cómo funciona tampoco hay
que yo creo que hay que criticar la
crisis la crítica lícita a las medidas
anti kobe no hay que juntarlos en el
mismo saco que el complot ismo y a veces
no sé si hemos podido caer en eso en
parte o no si es difícil poner la raya
donde empiezan explote y donde empiezan
pues las las dudas la zona crítica de
esta vacuna que me van a poner es segura
no segura es es una crítica razonable
pero bueno luego de también hay la gente
que aprovechando para cualquier cosa
hacer teorías de la conspiración
y a salir aquí poca la semana pasada
salí aquí un estudio en francia sobre
cómo era un poco el perfil del
complotista digamos que era y de otros
decían que era joven mujer y votante de
la extrema izquierda y la extrema
derecha que es súper modelos populistas
de izquierda sus populistas de derechos
y me parece curioso que las mujeres
serán más reticentes y también curioso
que los jóvenes fuesen también
reticentes lo que sí que es curioso es
que nunca o casi nunca te que es sólo un
complot es decir una vez que empiezas
con las teorías del complot
y crees que el hombre no llegó a la luna
llevando todas juntas el complot es es
muy atractivo en cuanto a peliculero no
me da una alternativa a una realidad
bastante difícil de llevar
es muy simple y el confinamiento y solá
mucho a las personas hay gente que no ha
podido ver a sus seres queridos o ver a
sí mismo a sus amigos y eso genera
muchos problemas de salud mental y
también de depresión acá en francia ha
habido un crecimiento exponencial
entonces uno se debilita mentalmente y
bueno
adepto a escuchar este tipo de teorías y
darle más credibilidad es muy atractivo
en cualquier caso en eeuu haremos lo
hemos visto ahora también con las
elecciones no que haya mucho que hay hay
teorías de complot por todos lados y
aquí también había muchas teorías de
complot siempre entre el 11-s cualquier
cualquier cosa
surge surge una teoría del complot o
pues ha sido un placer tenerles hoy con
nosotros aquí en primera plana
analizando esta segunda ola del cobismo
mucho más virulenta de lo que pensamos y
esperamos poder celebrar las navidades
no si son optimistas o no pero bueno yo
yo me quiero quedar aquí en francia no
voy a españa' tractores optimistas
celebraremos las navidades poquito
esperemos esperemos que así sea todos
ustedes muchísimas gracias y les
esperamos la próxima semana aquí en
primera plana de radio france
internacional y france 24 gracias
ah
[Música]